Hey everybody.
Welcome to another
fantastic episode
of Google Developers Live,
where we here at Google
get a chance to talk to you
about all the amazing things
going on on the web, in the
tech, and all the platforms
and the fantastic things
you can do with it.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
I'm a developer advocate
here on the Chrome team,
and I mostly work with web
performance issues as well as
web gaming.
Now, what I'd like
to talk to you today
about is something
that's very near and dear
and close to my heart,
and that's compression.
Today, we're going to be talking
about GZIP on the web platform
and how you can modify it
and address it and munge
it to try to minimize your
website memory footprint
and actually get
faster loading data.
Now, before we get into
this talk too much,
I'd actually like to point
out the #perfmatters hashtag.
This is a fantastic
hashtag that's
being used all
around the intertubes
on various social networks
for people in web performance
who are trying to
find the same problems
and address difficult issues
and have conversations
about performance in
interesting and insightful ways.
So use this hashtag.
If anything during this talk
is interesting or inspiring,
feel free to go to your favorite
social media network of choice.
It's a fantastic outlet, and
you need to be following it.
So with that, let's
get into things.
So let's start at the beginning.
I can't really talk about
compression on the web
without actually taking a look
at the state of the web today.
Now, besides being
filled with cats,
there's actually some
interesting data out there
for us to look at.
There's a great site
called httparchive.org,
and what this site
will do is actually
run large amounts of website
through processing filters
during the day.
So what will happen
is they'll take
300,000, 400,000
very common websites,
run them through a
processing system,
and then scrape
information about them
to present on their page.
Now, what you can see
here in this graph
is actually one of the
latest studies that
shows the average bytes of
a page per content type.
So what this graph
shows us is that images,
for an average site,
actually take up
the lion's share of the content
that's being streamed to users.
In fact, it's more than 50%.
It's actually a massive amount
of the content being delivered,
while scripts actually remain
the second largest, ending up
at around 260k or so.
Now, the interesting
thing about this
is when you look at the
individual response sizes,
you see a similar
trend, of course,
Flash being one of the largest
sizes per number of responses.
But of course, that
comes down to the fact
that you generally only have one
or two flashes per page where
they tend to be pretty large,
whereas JavaScript or PNGs
or JPEGs tend to be lots
of requests for a page.
That actually drives
that number down.
So what we're looking
at here is basically
a vision of the web that shows
that we're dominated by images
and we're dominated
by image data.
But I'm not
necessarily sure that
means that we can give up on
trying to minimize and reduce
the size of the text data
that actually drives our web.
So let's take a look at this.
This is another great set
of charts from HTTP Archive.
And effectively, what
you're looking at here
is three graphs showing
the transfer size
against the number of requests.
And so what you're
seeing is over time,
our number of requests have
remained pretty constant
over the past couple
of years, while you
see a general increasing
trend in the overall size
per request.
Now, this is
specifically three graphs
for HTML, JavaScript, and CSS.
What this is telling us is
that while images may make up
the lion's share of
the internet right now,
text information, the backbone
of these three formats,
isn't going away
anytime soon, nor is it
slated to get any smaller.
So for most people,
they would say, well,
if the web is mostly images,
why should we care about text?
Well, here's why.
You see, images may
be fantastic and they
may be the dominant
form of content for us,
but it's apparent and been
shown that they're not
as small as they could be.
So for example, let's
take this fantastic image,
which was captured on a camera.
This is about one
megapixel of data.
Now, if we say
this is a PNG file,
it actually comes out at
about 2.3 megabytes of data.
Now, for those of you
playing the home game,
you'll note that
HTTP Archive averages
that the average
website out there
is about 1.2 to
1.1 megs of data.
So this single PNG image,
if hosted on your website,
is already larger
than the average size
of a website on the internet.
Now, PNG's fantastic.
It allows you to
get transparency,
and it does support GZIP
compression internally
as a format, but it really only
supports a lossless encoding,
which means you're
not really getting rid
of any visual data
that may be redundant.
JPEG, on the other
hand, as a format
is built both a lossy
and lossless encoder.
This allows the JPEG encoding
system to actually remove
visually redundant
information from the image
so that you don't
really notice it's gone.
The human eye is pretty
complex, but still,
at 32 bits per pixel,
there's a lot of information
that we can't discern.
So if you JPEG this
image, you lose
the ability to get
transparency, however, you
do cut the size of the
image down to 297k.
Now, these have been the
two mostly dominant image
formats, besides animated
cat GIFs on the internet,
but earlier this year,
internet technology evangelists
and other enthusiasts
decided that maybe we
weren't done here yet.
Maybe the compression
system of JPEG
wasn't good enough for
the rest of the web,
and thus we had the
WebP format being born.
Now, the WebP format is new.
It's not necessarily
supported by all browsers
as of this date.
But it's actually got
some exciting properties
that are really making
people on the web
stand up and take notice.
So first off, if you compress
this image with WebP,
it actually drops to about 198k.
That's 100 kilobytes
of data difference
for this single image.
In addition to that,
WebP will actually
allow you to get
transparency and even
support some forms of animation,
which means this single image
format gets you the
compression sizes of JPEG,
the transparency
properties of PNG,
as well as the animation
properties of GIFs.
It's an exciting,
one stop solution
for a lot of your image needs.
Now, this is the important
thing to note about this image
size, and about
this image format,
is that most mobile phones
right now are actually
about five megapixels
for their cameras,
which means people are taking
snapshots of the food they eat
or signs on the
street or their kids,
uploading them to their
favorite social media network,
and that's actually coming in
at five megapixels uncompressed.
Now, if we look at PNG and
JPEG and the compression ratios
they got with a
single megabyte image,
you can see that over time,
as the number of images that
fill the internet
increases, we're
going to quickly run into
compression and data size
issues.
That's why WebP shows
up, and it actually
solves a huge problem
for us and allows
us to address a lot of issues.
Now, there's a whole separate
series of GDLs done on WebP.
I encourage you to go
to the GDL website,
take a look at
some of these talks
for more information on how
to get started with that.
Now, that's all I'm
going to say about image
compression for now.
But in the meantime,
let's talk about text.
So I said before that text
data-- CSS, HTML, JavaScript--
actually drive the rendering
performance and initial page
load of your page
more than images do.
This is for a very
specific reason.
So if you look at
this graph here,
we actually can't start
rendering anything on your page
until the HTML has been parsed
and subsequent JavaScript
and CSS may be loaded to create
both the DOM and the CSS DOM
so that we can actually
parse the render tree
and actually start getting
pixels on the screen.
So if we look at this average
flow of events from HTML
to CSS to actually
getting pixels there,
we can actually see an
interesting example.
So we have a standard HTML,
which actually links to a CSS.
That CSS is updating
some of the information
on the page, the text data.
We also have an image
that's referenced
and a script that's
at the bottom of it.
Now you can see on the
mobile image on the side
there that nothing
has been shown yet,
even though this
HTML has been parsed.
So we've got our little HTML
box that's mostly orange.
You can see that the DOM
has mostly been parsed.
It's partially orange.
And that the CSS
file-- example.css--
has been discovered, but it
hasn't really been loaded yet.
So this means that we
actually cannot display text
on the screen because we don't
have the styling properties
that define that
text on the screen.
It's not until the
CSS data actually
gets loaded that we can build
the CSS version of the DOM
and actually begin
constructing the render tree.
Now notice that the DOM still
hasn't finished loading yet.
That's OK.
If we can actually partially
load and partially display
the top part of the DOM, or
what people typically say
is above the fold, that allows
us to actually start rendering
pixels on the screen while
the bottom part of the page
is still loading.
So now that the
CSS has loaded, we
can actually get some
text on the screen.
Now notice that layout
and paint are halfway
through their process because
they don't have all the data.
Loading up next should be
WebP, and then of course,
last.js is defined
there as well.
Now, because of the
file sizes, last.js
is smaller than the image,
and so it can actually
get loaded and parsed
before the image
data actually gets
to the screen.
Now, if last.js kicks
off some style chains
or some other information
that needs to be loaded,
it can go back
and change the DOM
and change the CSS properties,
forcing page reflows,
forcing page repaints, and other
sorts of chaos in your loading
time.
But notice the image still
hasn't been loaded yet
and hasn't been
displayed on screen.
It's not until the final
complete bits come off
the wire, the CSS
DOM can be finished,
the render tree can
actually be completed,
and finally, we can
actually get the image
on the screen showing
you what we're
trying to show you
in the first place.
Now, what you should
gather from this
is that while images make up the
bulk of the content on the web,
it's really the
textual base data that
drives how and when
pixels get to your screen.
And when you're
trying to optimize
for fast path and critical path
rendering on mobile devices,
it's really the
text data you need
to get off the wire
as fast as possible.
Now, a lot of you
kids out there are
talking about some
really cool internet
technology called Emscripten.
Now, this is a library has
been developed open source that
allows developers to take
existing C and C++ code
and trans-compile that
to JavaScript data.
Probably one of the
most impressive examples
of this technology was debuted
a little bit earlier this year,
sometime in March at the game
developer conference, where
Nvidia and Mozilla and a
bunch of the open source
community at Emscripten actually
debuted the Unreal 3 graphics
engine running on
top of Emscripten.
Now, this means that you
get this rich, full graphics
engine running
inside of a browser.
It runs inside of
JavaScript, so it's
spec compliant and all
this other fun stuff.
Now, I'm from the
games industry,
and I've been working with
Unreal 3 for a number of years
now.
And one of the things
Unreal has never
been popular for is
being small in size.
You can actually see that
when we move the source
code and the compiled
data to the web,
this problem still consists.
So if you look at the loading
time of this application,
you can actually see
that the core JavaScript
file for this Emscripten-based
port of Unreal
is about 50 megabytes of data.
50 megabytes to bring
down a JavaScript
file to actually load this game.
Now to be fair, it
is served compressed,
which means that
you actually only
have to pull down
five megabytes of data
across the wire for this
single JavaScript file.
But still, five megabytes.
That's five times larger than
any of our other websites
out there.
And by the way, this isn't
counting the 18 megabytes
worth of data that has to
be pulled down as well.
So when you look at these
trends-- and the more
developers that are trying to
move towards high performance
JavaScript execution using
things like Emscripten
and asm.js-- what you
start seeing is a trend.
The more web applications
that produce source code
in JavaScript that come
from other languages,
we'll start seeing bloated
and larger and larger
JavaScript files that need to
be downloaded by their clients
before pixels can get
on the screen and a game
can be played.
This trend is not going
to diminish over time.
This means that our
text data is going
to continue growing larger.
As such, as a
developer, it's your job
to figure out how to
minimize, compress, and reduce
the number of bits on the wire.
And so with that,
let's take a look
at the good old
boy known as GZIP,
sort of the backbone of
compression on the internet
today.
Now, I want to do a quick side
to note that compression is not
the same as minimization
or minification,
depending on how purist
you are on the term.
So let's take a look at
the two really quick.
Minification in the
web platform is the art
of removing redundant
information from textual data
such that we can still
symbolically parse and process
it when we pass it off
to the underlying system.
So if you look at
this example here,
we've got a function
that adds two numbers,
but there seems like
there's a lot of information
that you don't see.
There's line returns, there's
extra spacing information,
perhaps the variable names
are actually too long.
The process of minification
actually reduces all of this
to give you the least number of
completely processing and valid
bytes for this file
representation.
Again here, we can
process this ahead of time
and actually pass this right
to the underlying systems
to be processed and actually
get stuff on your screen.
Now, compression,
on the other hand,
offers something
completely different.
Compression is the act of
modifying your data so that it
has to be reconstructed before
being passed to the underlying
processing system.
So again, if we take
the minimized form
of that some
function, compression
will actually turn it into
a bit stream of information
that then has to be deflated,
or actually decompressed
into the original form
before it can actually
be passed off to the
underlying systems.
These two technologies
work as a one-two punch.
So you actually have to add
minification to your technology
before you allow GZIP-ing
to occur in order
to get the fewest
bytes on the wire.
Now for the rest
of this talk, we're
actually going to be addressing
some of the issues and pros
and cons of GZIP,
but before we do
that, I need to make sure
that we understand what's
going on under the
hood of this algorithm.
You see, GZIP is a
compression format
that actually uses two
interplaying technologies
together.
The first one is a
technology known as LZ77.
Now, this is a
dictionary-based transform
that will actually take
a given data stream
and convert it into
a sequence of tuples.
Now, in each tuple, we actually
have a position and a length
value.
So I know that's confusing.
Let's take a look at
a little example here.
So we've got this
string up top which
is comprised of
various A, B's, and C's
in some sort of random order.
What happens is if we
start parsing this string,
we're going to look at
each symbol individually
and we're going to do a
scan backwards to find out
when previously we've
seen this symbol before,
because then that allows
us to actually encode
this symbol rather as a
single piece of information,
but actually as a relative
piece of information.
The goal here in
LZ77 is actually
to create a lot of
redundant types of tuples
that we can then compress
a little bit better.
So let's walk through
this just a little bit
so you can see what's going on.
So you see if we start
with the first A here
and we actually
parse it, well, it's
the beginning of the
string, so we haven't really
seen anything before yet.
Therefore, we actually
have to output
a position and length of 0, 0.
It represents that
we're not actually
seeing any other characters.
We're just looking
at the A itself.
Now, when we get to the second
A, we start our backwards scan
and we find that the
first A we encounter
was actually one symbol ago
at a length of one symbol.
So this means we can actually
output the tuple, 1, 1.
Now B, we haven't
seen any B's before,
so we have to output 0, 0.
And C, same thing, 0, 0.
But now we've reached
another B. So it's
going to start
scanning backwards
and actually finds that the last
B we encountered in the stream
was two symbols ago.
And again, we only
want length of one.
Now, the important and probably
the more interesting part
of this particular
example is when
we get to the end of the string
where we see A, B, C. Now,
when we scan backwards
from A, B, C,
we can actually find that we
found this exact three symbol
value previously in
our stream, and exactly
about five character
positions back.
So this means we're going
to output the tuple of 5, 3.
So we output a tuple rather
than the three characters
themselves.
Now again, the point of
LZ77 is to actually create
duplicate and high
redundancy tuples.
These tuples and the
redundancy that we
create with them are actually
very important to pass off
to the next step of
the GZIP algorithm
known as Huffman compression.
Now, for those of you who don't
remember Huffman compression
or probably have blocked
it out of your mind back
from the Computer Science
101 days at your university,
Huffman works by assigning
variable length bit codes
to symbols in your stream
based on probability.
The idea here is that the more
probable and more frequent
a symbol is in your
stream, the least bits
you should use to represent it.
A perfect real world example of
Huffman encoding is Morse code.
In the American
language, the letter E
is the most dominant
of all our words.
Therefore, it's
assigned a single beep
to represent its value.
Huffman compression
works in a similar way.
Now, we're going to spare
you the knowledge of building
a Huffman tree and
everything else.
This is in tons of
data structures books.
Instead, we'll just
show you that we
can see after we parse our
newly tokenized tuple string,
you can see that 0, 0 is
the most dominant tuple set.
And of course, we
can assign that one
bit, being a single zero.
Therefore, the next
set is actually 1, 1.
We have two symbols of that.
And because of the way
our tree is constructed,
we actually have to provide
that with two bit symbols.
We continue on and continue
on and effectively keep
assigning variable bit
code words to symbols,
creating a compressed
version of our data.
Now, these two characters
or these two algorithms
operating back and
forth with each other
actually have a very
beautiful ballet
in the way that
content is created
and how it's compressed with
the statistical encoding.
This is the cornerstone
of everything
we're going to talk about for
the rest of this conversation.
Now, it's worth pointing
out that GZIP is not
the only kid on the block.
In fact, GZIP is about 20
something years old now.
If it were a real
human being, it
would be able to
drink and drive and do
all other sorts of fun
stuff on the internet.
But other compression
algorithms which
may be a little bit newer
and a little bit different
can actually give you some
interesting trade-offs.
So here are four of the more
popular encoders out there.
The first is one known as LZMA.
Some of you may know
this more popularly
as 7-Zip, a very
popular compression
archive tool out there.
You can see that LZMA
actually gives you
smaller compression than GZIP.
This is actually due to
a lot of higher order
searching and finding algorithms
built around that LZ77
algorithm.
In fact, LZMA can actually be
considered a distant cousin
to GZIP because it's actually
very similar in the way
that it compresses its data.
However, because it uses
more modern heuristics
and algorithms, it can
actually get better results.
Now, below LZMA, you see LPAQ.
This is a context
mixing based encoder.
It's effectively
mostly a neural net
in practice of how
it matches symbols.
Now notice LPAQ
actually gives us
the smallest file size
compared to everything else
at 0.35 megabytes.
I'll get into that a little
bit more in a second.
Now, the final compressor we
look at is actually BZIP2.
Now, BZIP is a modern variant
of the Burrows-Wheeler transform
assigned also with a
move to front transform
and either a Huffman
or an arithmetic
encoder on the back end.
Now, BZIP2 fundamentally changes
the way that compression works.
It's very different.
Doesn't use LZ77 at all.
Instead, it uses
a semi-block based
sorting transform
to actually increase
redundancy or adjacent
redundancy in data.
This redundancy allows it
to get better compression.
Again, you can see here
where GZIP actually gives us
0.48 in terms of megabytes,
BZIP actually beats this.
Now, what you're actually
seeing here in terms of data
sizes is actually a scrape I
did of the amazon.com home page.
So if I take all
of the text data
from that-- HTML, CSS,
JSON, and JS data--
it actually comes out
to about 1.64 megs.
So you can see how
these compressors relate
to that specific
memory footprint.
Now, when you're
comparing compressors,
the size of the data is
not the only heuristic.
You have two other
heuristics that you typically
throw into the mix.
The first one is encoding
time and the second one
is decoding time, which often is
the more important of the two.
So if we look at the
encoding time column,
you can see that GZIP does
probably the fastest in terms
of encoding speed
at 0.79 seconds.
LZMA, being a distant cousin
with more search heuristics,
actually comes in
pretty close at 1.26.
You can see that the wins
it gets in compression size
actually come from
more preprocessing
at the front of
the encoding step.
Now, LPAQ gives you
amazing compression,
but notice it actually takes 11
seconds to compress your data.
Now again, LPAQ is
a modern wonder.
It actually uses
various forms of context
mixing in different
sort of combinations,
again, resulting in pretty
much an artificial intelligence
neural net algorithm to
find compression wins.
So it makes sense
that this actually
oscillates at about 11 seconds
worth of processing time
because there's a lot of
things going on under the hood.
Meanwhile, the Burrows-Wheeler
transform powered BZIP2
doesn't stray too
far from the mark,
but gives us about 2.1
seconds in encoding time.
And there's a
whole set of papers
that talk about how that
clustering transform actually
affects memory and
processing and whatnot.
Now, decoding time is probably
the most important part here.
You can actually see
that GZIP and LZMA are,
for all practical
purposes, identical.
So while LZMA takes a
little bit longer to encode,
it seems to regularly produce
smaller files than GZIP,
and the decoding time tends
to be almost identical.
Now, LPAQ, again, because
it's running a neural net,
the decode time actually
equals almost what
the encode time was, so you
look at about 11 seconds
there, while BZIP
actually is a faster
decode than it is an encode.
The whole point of this
slide-- the only thing
I want you to take
away from here--
is that GZIP is really
good at a couple things,
specifically encoding time.
It gets beat in a couple
places, specifically
with the size of the compression
that it achieves, and then ties
in a couple other
places in decoding time.
So it's not really the
only algorithm on the block
there in terms of
compression ratios.
So you can see here
that we've highlighted
a couple of these
specific instances.
LPAQ wins in size.
Encoding time is, of
course, dominated by GZIP,
and decoding time is, of
course, dominated by LZMA.
Now, this can lead a lot of
people on the web tech platform
to actually come at me
with burning pitchforks
and actually say, hey, GZIP
is actually pretty good.
That data just showed
us that we really
don't need any other compression
algorithms because it gives us
decent size compression,
decent time for encoding,
and decent decoding time.
Well, I'm here to tell you
that's a good argument,
but let's dig a
little bit deeper into
whether or not GZIP should
be the only thing we
allow on the web.
So first off, you should
understand that there's really
no silver bullet
for compression.
Depending on what your
data is, how frequent
it is, the relationships it
has with local information,
all relate to how well it
can be compressed at the end,
and different compressors
will handle this data
in different ways.
For example, if you actually
applied JPEG style compression
to text data, you're
not going to be
able to decompress your
text in the right way
because it's lossy in terms
of removing information
bits from the stream itself.
So let's take a perfect
example that actually
shows to beat GZIP without
really any modification.
So let's say we have a
string of integers here.
Now, this string of
integers was actually
created as an index system into
some higher order database.
So there's basically 10
things that are being indexed,
and we list them here.
Now, if we just GZIP
this, we actually
don't get a lot of savings.
This is because,
if you remember,
the LZ77 algorithm
isn't going to find
any duplicate indexes
in this array.
Nine is only existing once,
and so are the other numbers.
Meanwhile, that means that all
of the statistical probability
for these symbols is
pretty much equal.
There's no difference.
Nothing is more frequent
or less frequent,
which means the Huffman
algorithm is going
to pretty much assign
equal bit lengths to all
the symbols themselves.
Because of this, we really don't
get any compression savings
at all from the GZIP algorithm
for this particular data
stream.
This means that you have
to look at your data
and go, what is
GZIP doing to it?
If we, however, take a
little bit different swing
at the problem itself,
we can actually
beat what GZIP is doing with a
little knowledge of our data.
So let's say we take
the original array,
and instead of just
leaving it by itself,
we actually notice the
property that we can actually
sort this information because
we don't need the order
to come out on the backside.
So if we sort this,
we actually end up
with a pretty incrementing
run of numbers-- zero to nine
without any gaps in the middle.
We can take this string
and apply a technique known
as delta encoding to actually
create a different symbol set.
Now, delta encoding
works by taking a symbol
and finding the
difference in the symbol
between the previous symbol,
and it encodes the difference
rather than the actual value.
So for our specific
example here,
we start with the number
zero, and the number one
is one more, so we
add one to that.
Two is greater than
one by a single value,
so we had one, one,
one, one, one, one.
And you can see
with delta encoding,
all we have to do is encode
one and then eight zeros
to actually represent the
original string we have.
Now, the delta encoded
version, notice
that it does have a lot
of duplicate symbols,
and there is a
particular symbol which
is more dominant than
the other symbols.
Now, once we've encoded
our data into this form,
GZIP actually has a field day.
The LZ77 algorithm finds lots
of matches in its window,
and the arithmetic
compressor can actually
come through and assign
smaller bit codes
to more frequent streams.
What we're showing you
here is that you can't just
throw arbitrary data
at GZIP and expect
to get the most perfect,
amazing form of compression.
Instead, a little
bit of preprocessing
can actually change the
way your compression works,
most of the time for the better.
Now, let's look at
another perfect example
of where GZIP can actually
cause some problems.
So if you look at my website, I
did a little bit of an analysis
a while ago on various forms of
CSS minimization technologies.
There was a
fantastic set of code
out there by someone who
was using genetic algorithms
to figure out optimal
ways to minify CSS data.
So let's take a look
at this table here.
So if we take two CSS files from
StackOverflow and Bootstrap,
and we actually look at
their minified forms--
so this has already been run
through Closure or YUI or Clean
CSS, one of these things-- we
actually get about 90 and 97k,
respectively.
Now, using the genetic
algorithm version
of the minifier actually
produced about 3% savings
in both of these
files, which meant
that we can use a different
variant of minification to get
wins over what we're
typically already doing.
So this is a good idea.
If we find a better algorithm
that minifies our data smaller,
we should be embracing that.
This is where GZIP actually
causes some trouble.
When we actually run these
genetically algorithmically
minimized data through
the GZIP compressor,
you can see the results
are actually negative.
That means it's actually
growing the data.
So we have our minified.GZIP.
So if we just zip the data
that comes from Clean CSS
or Closure, we get
about 18 and 15k.
However, when we
zip the data that's
been generated from
our genetic algorithm,
you can see that we're
actually increasing
the size of the file.
Basically, what you're
seeing is that the data is so
minimized coming from
the genetic algorithm
that GZIP is actually
inflating the data.
It's making your
file larger than it
should be because it's only
using the LZ77 and Huffman
encoding steps.
Now, this should
scare a lot of people,
hopefully, into thinking
how often this is actually
occurring on the internet
for various size of files.
Now, I can tell you
it's not that frequent,
but it is something to keep an
eye on because it definitely
shows that GZIP is
not a silver bullet
and that it can actually
do harmful things in very
certain circumstances.
Now of course, a
lot of people here
would then say, well,
this means we shouldn't
be using this genetic
algorithm to minimize our CSS.
Obviously, that's a flop.
And I still think that
that's the wrong argument,
but let's move on.
Now, let's talk
about PNG for minute.
Now, PNG is a format
that you can actually
export in a compressed form.
Now internal to PNG, the
compression algorithm it uses
is called deflate, pretty much
the backbone of what GZIP uses.
It's LZ77 coupled with a
Huffman compressor step.
Now, what you're looking at on
the screen here is two images.
Effectively, I took a 90
pixel by 90 pixel sprite,
and I tiled it vertically,
creating a 90 by 270 image.
Now, I resized that
image just a little bit
and added two columns of
pixels, so we now have a 92
by 270 image instead
of a 90 by 270.
So we've barely altered
the size of the data.
However, you can
see at the bottom
there that the sizes post-GZIP
are drastically different.
The 90 by 270
image is about 20k,
while the 92 pixel image is 41k.
That's twice as large for
only two columns of pixels
being added to the image.
And again, the
compression algorithm
that's being used under the
hood here is effectively GZIP.
So let's take a look at
why this is occurring
and what's going on.
So let's say we've got a
bunch of pixel colors here.
Well remember,
the LZ77 algorithm
is going to come
through, and it's
going to try to find matches.
So we've got a particular
green pixel here
and another green
pixel that's identical
to this somewhere previous
in our data stream.
Now, how this works is that
LZ77 won't scan infinitely
to try to find matches.
Instead, it actually
operates in a window
of 32k worth of information.
Now, that means if I
encounter a symbol that's
outside of that window, then
I'm not going to find a match.
It only matches things
inside of a 32k window.
So if we look at
our 90 by 90 images
that we created for
our tile sheet there,
90 times 90 times
4 bytes per pixel
is roughly about 32k in size.
Now, if we actually
look at 32 times 1,024,
the real definition
of 32k, it's,
again, about 300 bytes
larger than our 90 by 90.
However, when we added
those two columns of pixels,
we actually changed the size
and the stride of our images.
90 by 92 by 4 is
actually 33k, not 32k.
What this means
is that when we're
trying to find duplicate
pixels in this image,
we're just far enough away that
we can't find the exact pixel
that we had seen before.
Let's take a look
at this visually.
So again, we have our two
images, the 20k and the 41k,
and we can actually
create a heat map
for this image representation.
Now, this heat map shows
us in dark blue pixels
being the ones that
are highly compressed.
This is where matches
have been found.
They're very small, encoded
pixels at this point.
Meanwhile, reds and yellows mean
that we didn't find a match,
and to encode this particular
pixel took a lot more bits.
So you can see on the left hand
side, where we're 90 by 270,
we actually get a
lot more matches.
The dominant form of
the image is dark blue.
You can see once we tiled that
image in the lower two regions,
that we find an exact pixel
matching 32k pixels away.
However, when we increase
the size by two columns,
we've actually bumped out the
window of pixels to look at.
Therefore, we're not actually
finding exact matches.
In fact, we have to
look for near matches,
and that's why the second
image has a lot more misses
in the LZ77 cache,
resulting in worse encoding.
Now, this basically shows
us that with small changes
to our image data, the
GZIP algorithm actually
falls completely on its face.
Again, it's far from
being a silver bullet.
Now, the truth is that at this
time you should be saying,
well hey, it'd be
great if we could
use one of the newer algorithms.
But in reality,
we're stuck with GZIP
for some indefinite future.
Here's why.
If you actually go to
the Chromium source code
and look at the bug system
that's provided there,
you'll find an interesting
tale of how Chrome actually
adopted the BZIP2
compression format.
Effectively, Chrome
added support for it,
and a lot of servers--
Apache and whatnot--
added support to send
out BZIP2 content.
So effectively, a server creates
a BZIP2 file instead of GZIP
and sends it off to servers.
However, what started
happening in the wild
was a little bit
interesting to us,
and the results made
us actually have
to remove the support
for BZIP2 from Chrome.
You see, what was happening
was a lot of these middle boxes
that are out there in
the wild didn't ever
expect that we would do
anything besides GZIP,
and they actually had hard coded
paths in there to look and say,
if this is not GZIP
header compressed,
compress it with GZIP.
So effectively, what occurred
was some servers, when
they received the BZIP2
archive or the BZIP2 header,
and these middle boxes
would look at it and say,
hey, this isn't GZIP.
Strip the header, try
to GZIP the information,
and then send it out.
This means Chrome would
actually receive a BZIP2 data
package whose header
had been stripped
and then it had been re-gzipped.
So we would have no idea what
the actual format of the data
is that we're receiving.
It could be binary data,
or it could actually
be valid information.
The problem was this was
so systemic out there
in the wild for various types
of firmware and middle boxes
that it was actually
too difficult for us
to fix on the fly, which
means it was a smarter idea
to actually just remove
this from Chrome.
So when you start
talking about the ability
to add other compression
algorithms to the base browser,
you're going to run
into the same problem.
There's a lot of
systems out there
who just don't
understand and haven't
been updated to expand to
different sorts of compression
technologies.
So this gets us to an
interesting idea of well,
if we're stuck with GZIP, but
size of text data is a problem,
how do we actually create
smaller GZIP files?
Well lucky for
you, I've actually
spent the past three or four
months focusing explicitly
on this problem,
and you can actually
see a lot of the results on my
blog at mainroach.blogspot.com.
But first, let's dive into
a couple of these ideas,
and then you can
go there and read
about all the awesome things.
So first off, we can actually
generate better GZIP files.
A lot of people don't
understand this,
but when your server creates
your GZIP file, a lot of them
are only tuned to compress
it at a factor of six.
The command line parameter
that you pass to GZIP
allows you to pass in
between zero and nine,
where most of the servers
are default set to six.
This seems to be an
interesting trade-off
between compression speed
and compression size.
Now, this is mostly
because web developers
tend to just upload raw
assets to the server,
not wanting to deal
with compression.
The server actually is
responsible for compressing
the content and then
sending it off to requests.
Now, what's
interesting about this,
though, is that you
can modify your files
and actually GZIP them offline.
So effectively,
part of your build
step would be to take
your text information,
GZIP it with some better
compressor to produce a smaller
GZIP file, and then
actually tell the server
to just pass that data through.
There's two applications out
there that could actually
produce this type of
smaller GZIP file.
The first one is 7-Zip.
This is actually a
very nice command line
tool which can produce BZIP2
archives as well as GZIP
archives, but it does
so taking advantage
of the more modern,
more powerful searching
and dictionary based
compression algorithms
that it's going to be using.
So 7-Zip can actually produce
smaller versions of GZIP files
than the standard command
line GZIP archiver
that ships with most
firmware in servers.
Another fantastic tool out
there is one called Zopfli.
Now, this was actually
created by the engineers
here at Google to solve
this same problem.
Now, Zopfli uses a lot more
memory and a lot more advanced
algorithms than even 7-Zip to
find better matches in smaller
spaces to produce smaller
GZIP files as well.
It's an open source project.
You can go check it out.
I highly recommend it
if you're interested.
So the cool thing is we can
use either 7-Zip or Zopfli
as part of your build process to
actually generate smaller text
files and have them sent
along on behalf of the user.
And again, these are
GZIPs, so they're
going to be accepted by
the middle boxes as well
as the browsers.
Now, if you're wondering
how these preprocessing
systems actually fare
against the standard GZIP,
here's a great graph to look at.
So you can actually
see the blue column
across the bunch of files is
actually the standard GZIP
algorithm.
The red one is actually
Zopfli, and the green one
is actually 7-Zip.
So you can see
across these 42 files
that on average, in fact,
most of the time, both Zopfli
and 7-Zip regularly beat GZIP
by somewhere between 2% to 10%.
And if you actually
increase your parameters
and allow Zopfli and 7-Zip to
spend more time doing matching
and doing compression,
you can actually
get it into the 15%
ratio, which is fantastic.
Now, the cost of this,
though, is enormous.
A lot of these algorithms
took probably 20 minutes
to run-- on the light
side-- to find 1% to 5%
worth of compression wins.
Basically, what we
found is that we're
at a local minima
for compression.
The more time we spend trying
to compress the content
yields less and less
and less actual savings.
You could spend
six hours of cloud
compute time to get 2% savings
in your compression algorithm.
So at this point, you
have to look and say,
well, if we're stuck
with GZIP, yet it
takes additional hours of
time to compute smaller GZIP
files, what the heck is
this entire talk about?
Aren't we just stuck in this?
Fret not, my good friends.
You're actually not
stuck, and it actually
comes down to you
owning your data.
You see, you can create
smaller GZIP files
by actually preprocessing
your information
before handing it off to GZIP.
Much like the example
I gave earlier
where we took a set of numbers
and then delta compressed them
to create something that was
highly repetitive and highly
compressible, you can
apply these techniques
to a lot of other portions
of your code base.
So let's dive into some
interesting algorithms
you can use in your
projects today.
The first one happens to be
close and near to my heart.
Now, many applications
and many websites
out there use JSON as
a format to transfer
data between client and server.
Social media
information is typically
sent around in this information.
It's a very nice, very
adopted file format
for sending information around,
particularly because it's
built off the
JavaScript standard.
Now, when you're sending
this data around,
though, most of the time,
users and developers
don't think about how to
modify the data being sent such
that it compresses better.
So a user asks for
some search query.
The server goes and
computes the information
and then returns
the JSON blob back,
normally optimizing for
return round trip time.
It's trying to get the
data back to the user
as fast as possible.
But what they don't
understand is if they actually
have that GZIP flag
turned on, GZIP
is going to stop the
operation and zip the content
before sending it down
to the client anyway.
Now, if you're the
type of developer
that's dealing in third world
countries or other types
of connectivity that may
be sparse or intermittent,
this is actually a huge problem
because your client device--
usually a mobile device
on some 1G or 2G network
that may or may not
stay consistent--
is sending off
requests, and then
what's hurting them
is that they're
getting a larger
payload coming down.
So basically, what we're
talking about now is,
how can you process
your JSON blobs that
are being returned to these
individuals in such a way
that GZIP can
compress it further?
And it all starts
with the ability
to transpose your structured
data in your JSON file.
So let's take a look
at this example.
Now, I've scraped
a lot of websites
and a lot of JSON
responses, and I
see this pattern occur
on a lot of websites.
Effectively, what
you're looking at
is a list of dictionary
structures of name value pairs.
So if someone requests a
search for a particular item
on a shopping website,
it's very common
to actually return to them a
dictionary item that actually
contains what the product
name is, what the price is,
what thumbnail image to use,
et cetera, and then just
list these linearly
inside of an array.
So what this creates, though,
as an interesting problem,
is that similar based
data is actually
strided away from each other.
It's actually interleaved.
So you may have a
name and then a price,
which could be a floating point
value, and then a description,
which may be a long
form block of text,
and then a URL, which has its
own specific characteristics.
What we're proposing
in transposing our data
is actually turning
this name value pair
and actually de-interleaving it,
and instead actually grouping
similar values for
property names together.
So example here is we have these
two dictionary objects that
both have name and
position values,
and instead, we can
transpose that such
that we have an
array of name answers
and an array of pos answers.
Now, I know this
looks weird at JSON,
so let's take a
graphical look at things.
So let's say on the
top here, we have
an array where we have
a list of objects,
and each one of
the colored blocks
represents a property
on that object.
So we've got green is a name,
and blue may be a price point,
and again, red
might be some URL.
What we can do, then,
is we can actually
transpose this and align all of
the green blocks, blue blocks,
and red blocks together,
allowing homogeneous data
to reside in an array with
other homogeneous data.
Now, I'm going to explain
why this is actually
an improvement in a
second, but let's see
if we can take a look at whether
or not this saves us any data.
So if we take a
bunch of JSON files
that are returned from
very common websites--
so I took some responses
from Amazon and Pinterest
and whatnot-- you can see that
the first column represents
the source size in
bytes, the second column
represents the source
data actually gzipped.
The third is actually
the size of the data
after it's been transposed.
You can see that there's
some variability in numbers
there because we're
actually removing symbols
from the string at this point.
And you can see the
final column is actually
the gzipped version of
the transposed data.
Now, we're actually in an
interesting situation here,
is that for some JSON files,
the transposed gzipped data
is actually smaller than the
source gzipped data, which
means we actually get a win
by applying this process.
Thankfully, we're not
falling into that area
where genetic algorithm
minimized CSS is actually
causing GZIP to
inflate the data.
We don't want to be there.
So the transpose operation
actually gives us
smaller files,
which is fantastic.
Now, the reason that
this actually works
has to do with the
32k window that LZ77
uses for its matching.
So if we have our
values here that
are all interleaved-- red,
green, blue, red, green, blue,
red, green, blue-- again, we
have to go farther to search
for a piece of content
that may be an exact match.
However, when we transpose
our data, we de-interleave it
and group similar
types of data together.
So let's say we're
actually trying
to find a match for one
of these green values.
In the top array, you can see
that an entire listing of data,
the green may not fit
inside the 32k window.
Meanwhile, once we transpose
it and group homogeneous data
together, the entirety
of the green data
actually fits in
a single window.
This is going to allow you
to find better matches, which
is going to result in
smaller compression values.
Now this actually comes to
another step here, which is OK,
well, if we can
transpose our data,
how else might we
modify our content
so that we can get wins?
Now, this is a really,
really cool algorithm
that I found digging
through the archives of IEEE
known as compression boosting.
Now, it operates on
the same parameters.
How do we preprocess things
for better compression?
So the first one we're
going to take a look at here
is actually something
called Dense Codes.
Now, this is some great
research out of some academics
in Argentina, and
effectively, it
allows us to take a text
based file and preprocess
it and hand it off to GZIP.
Now, the preprocessing
is actually
the important part here.
We're not actually
transposing it,
but instead, were using a
modified dictionary index
lookup scheme.
So let's say we parse
our text and our seen,
and we create a
dictionary index.
So once a word is seen, we
provide it to the dictionary,
and then every
reference to that word
is replaced with an
index value to the array.
So let's say we have an array
here of, "How much would could
a woodchuck chuck," and we
have 400 symbols before that.
So we see that "how" is at
location 400, 401 is "much,"
402 is "wood," 403 is "could."
So when we're creating
a stream, we're
going to get values that point
into these element arrays.
So the problem with this is that
if we only have 256 symbols,
we can only use eight
bits per pointer.
However, if we go
above 256, we have
to start using 16 bits per
pointer, which is actually
a problem because if the
symbols are weighted such
that the most probable
and most visible
symbols are actually closer to
the front of the dictionary,
you're actually going to
be wasting a lot of space.
You're going to have a lot of
symbols and a lot of indexes
where the first upper
eight bits are actually
going to be zeros for the
entire dominant side of it.
So you're actually
inflating the size
of your stream at this
point because there's
a lot of bits that
aren't being used.
Now, the way that
Dense Codes work is it
actually allows you to modify
the way the token is used
to create the ability
to actually do
variable length coding
in string, which means
that for the first
three numbers,
we actually use 16 bits
to represent the indexes,
but the second three numbers,
because their indexes
are lower than 256,
we can actually
use eight bits instead of 16.
This is actually going to
create a smaller stream for us
to actually compress
a little bit later.
Now, the wins from
this are pretty
interesting to look
at because there's
a couple things in
flight here, and I've
got an entire 10-page writeup
on my blog about this algorithm
and the interesting things that
go back and forth between it,
some caveats, and some
things you need to know,
but it all boils
down to this table.
Now basically, what
this table says
is that we've tried the
source data being gzipped,
and then we've
tried the data being
run through our
dense codes-- that's
the ETDC column-- and then the
gzipping of that information.
Now, next to it, I actually
compare the other compressors
that we've mentioned today--
Zopfli, 7-Zip, and BZIP2.
So what I'm trying
to see here is
once I do this preprocessing,
what compression algorithm is
actually going to give
us the best results?
You can see that hands
down, GZIP really
doesn't produce savings with
this preprocessing method
for the majority of
the data that I've
shown here-- JSON files, CSSs.
And I've actually
run this probably
against 25,000,
30,000 files, and you
see this similar pattern,
that just doing standard GZIP
against this information
doesn't really give you wins.
However, you see when
you start using Zopfli,
you start getting some wins.
The advanced pattern matching
and more memory usage
characteristics that it
has inside of an encoder
allows you to get better
matches with this,
producing smaller files.
The clear winner here is 7-Zip.
Something inside of the way
it's using its algorithms
consistently produces smaller
dense code compressed files
as opposed to the
source data, which
means this is interesting,
that if you have
data that's above
a certain size.
Let's say you're returning a 20k
blob of data for some reason.
Preprocessing that
text with dense codes
and then using 7-Zip as
your compressor of choice
can actually produce smaller
GZIP files consistently.
Now, the downside
of this, of course,
is that you have to reconstruct
your dense code transform
at the client, but that's
not necessarily a big deal
depending on what
type of trade-off
you're willing to make.
Now, these are all
preprocessing schemes.
There's another form of
processing your data that
can actually get wins
that these can't touch.
I mean, the types
of wins that we're
going to talk about
for Delta.js blow
these preprocessing schemes out
of the water, but be warned.
Thar be dragons here, mostly
in the form of madness.
So let's dive into what
I'm talking about here.
So in 2012, the
Gmail team actually
did a fantastic
presentation for the W3C,
and actually put
up some slides that
are publicly available to other
information, that was proposing
a solution to a common problem.
You see, Gmail users
see about 61 years
of loading bar inside of
Gmail about every day.
This is a lot of time that
users are sitting around,
waiting for JavaScript
to be streamed out.
What they proposed was
a new form of ability
to, instead of transferring the
large files every single time,
they can actually start
transferring the difference
between the file
that the user has
and the new file
that the user needs.
Now, this isn't a new concept.
We've seen these sorts
of patching-based systems
everywhere in computing
since the late 1970s,
but it's never been
able to be applied
to the web due to some of
the architecture involved.
How the algorithm works is this.
So let's say we have a
file, file.CSS version zero,
and we've made an update to it.
This happens quite a
bit in large projects.
Now, when we make that update,
the majority of the file
is the same as it used to be.
There may be a
function that's added,
or some comments were placed
in, or some things were removed,
but for the majority
of the file,
it's almost
identical, which means
we can represent the
second file, the new file,
as a difference from the
file that we've already seen.
This is the concept,
again, of delta encoding.
Now, once we've delta
encoded this file,
the patch-- basically the
difference between the two--
is generally much, much smaller
than the updated version
of the file, which
means we can represent
version one as a patch
operation of version zero.
This means that if
the user already
has version one on their
machine, all we have to do
is send them the
patch, and it allows
them to reconstruct and create
the new version of the data.
Now, this is actually a
pretty interesting concept
because this means
we don't have to send
full files to the
clients all the time.
Instead, we can produce and send
down highly, highly minimized
content to these guys.
Now of course, this comes
with a bit of overhead
in terms of communication.
You see, in order
to get this working,
we have to have a
communication process
between the client
and the server.
So let's say we have
our mobile device here
and the user is going
to load a website.
Well, the client
actually needs to notify
the server on what version
of the file it has cached.
The server can then
take this information,
look up in its
array, and figure out
what patch file it needs
to send to the client
in order to get them up to date.
Once it's figured this out, it
passes it off to the client,
and then the client is
going to use this patch
to construct the new version
of the file and cache that
and use that appropriately.
Effectively, this technique
is trading network requests
for smaller file sizes.
Sending a couple byte
request to determine
what version of
the file you have
is going to be night and day
difference than actually doing
the entire file being sent
to the user multiple times.
Now, if this sounds like
craziness to you, just hold on.
You have to realize
this is a common problem
for many large, very
industrial websites
that serve millions
of users a day.
You see, when the
Gmail people actually
looked at the type
of savings they
can get from this
type of algorithm,
they saw a massive potential
for improvement here.
You see, when they
compared the number of revs
they do to a single file
over a month against the size
of the deltas if they
were using this scheme,
they actually saw that a
whole month's worth of changes
was about 9%-- lower than
9%-- of the size of the assets
altogether, which
means they would only
have to send 9% of the content
as opposed to the new full file
each time.
This is a huge win.
We're not talking
about 10% improvement.
about 50% improvement.
This is 90% size decrease by
using this delta algorithm.
So obviously, this was a
proposal to the W3C spec.
I've talked with some
of the Gmail guys.
It doesn't look like this is
actually live in the servers
right now.
If that's changed, I hope
to be wrong because this
is a fantastic
piece of technology
that I hope to see
rolling out in some form
to a lot of other
distributors on the internet.
Now, there's another
form of this compression
that I've actually been
playing around with.
It actually comes in the form
of horizontal compression.
Typically, when we think of
delta encoding for files,
we think in terms of patches.
I've got version
A and version B,
and I want to generate
the patch between the two.
This is especially common
in game development.
However, there exists a
form called horizontal.
How this works is
let's say we have
a cascade of files that may
be similar on a website.
So this particular website
uses three CSS files.
Let's say it's Bootstrap
or something like that.
Well, the interesting thing is
that these CSS files generally
aren't that different
from each other.
There's actually a lot a shared
syntax on a website for a given
CSS file, which
means that instead
of doing delta compression
between versions of the file,
we can actually do delta
compression between the files
that are going to
be sent to the user.
So we can actually do a
difference between file zero
and file one, and then
file one and file two.
This actually allows
us to create patches
for each one of
these, and when we
combine that with the
source file to your server,
the size of the assets that need
to be sent down to the client
is drastically reduced.
We can actually send them
the entire application
and all the content required
as deltas from base files.
This, again, is just
an extrapolation
of various forms
of delta algorithms
that are already
used out in the wild.
Now, how this works
on the client side
is that the server
will, of course, provide
to the client the base file
and the set of patches,
and then the client is
responsible for reconstructing
each one of those files and
then caching them locally.
This is a really
neat idea if you're
trying to optimize first
time load for users.
The Gmail proposed
specification requires
that the user has to download
version zero of the file, which
in some cases actually
could be 300k of CSS data.
Meanwhile, horizontal
compression
suggests that it may
not have to do that.
It may only have to send down
bites or chunks of 50k data
when you actually represent
that CSS as a delta.
Effectively, what you're doing
in this horizontal scheme is
you're trading client side
processing for smaller transfer
sizes.
This is because it actually
takes a lot of CPU cycles
on the client to reconstruct
these files before passing them
off to the processing
system to create
your DOM and everything else.
So there's this interesting
trade-off between Delta.js
or vertical delta encoding for
files and the horizontal delta
encoding for files as well.
Now, we can see when I've
applied this technique
to some various
sites on the internet
that we actually get some
interesting numbers out of it.
So I took all of the CSS
from a Gmail session,
all of the JavaScript
and all of the CSS
from an Amazon session,
and I ran it through
this technique.
So you can see we've
got the source, the GZIP
source, and then
the size of the data
once it's been delta
encoded, and then
of course, the gzipping
of the delta encoded data
because we can't just stop
at the delta encoding.
So you can see for
Gmail, we actually
get some pretty amazing
savings, 31% and 12%,
by using this horizontal
delta compression encoding.
Meanwhile, something weird's
going on with the Amazon data
where we actually get an
increase of size by 13%.
Now, I'd like to
actually point out
that this data is highly, highly
minimized and highly redundant.
All of these files that are
creating multiple network
requests tend to
be self similar,
and that's actually due to the
minification processes that
are being applied to
these files on the web.
To give you an example of
how important minimization
is to horizontal
delta compression,
let's take a look at the game
library known as Impact.js.
I love this library.
It's fantastic.
If you're a game
developer and you're
looking to make HTML5
games, definitely
give Impact.js a look.
Effectively, I took
the source file
and left them as loose files.
I did not combine them
into a single large file.
I actually created the delta
between all these files
and then did the
gzipped version of that.
Now, you can see
that it actually
goes down from about 70k to 21k.
However, when I minimized
all of the files
before doing delta
compression, I actually
got a better savings.
I got down to about 14k.
This is because the
minimization techniques
we're using on the
web today actually
produce a lot of
duplicate symbols
that could be used
in various places.
Again, when you see
those original examples
of taking some and we
renamed the parameters that
are being passed
to it as ABC, we
tend to see that pattern
occur for all the JavaScript
for every function
that's been defined,
meaning we're going
to see more matches.
More matches result in better
statistical probability,
which results in
smaller file sizes.
So by minimizing our data before
we do our delta compression,
we actually get very,
very important wins.
So what we've talked
about today is
where GZIP sits on
the web platform.
We've got a lot of text data
that's about to blow up.
We've got mobile devices.
We've got fragmented hardware.
We've got different
connectivity all over the world,
but some things here allow you
to take advantage and actually
address these issues
today rather than waiting
for network times to increase.
So for example, we
looked at the fact
that GZIP is not
a silver bullet.
By preprocessing your
data, you can actually
get some pretty big wins.
We've seen where GZIP
actually falls on its face.
If you've done a lot
of preprocessing,
it may not compress your
data, and in fact, it
might inflate it.
Or in the case of PNGs,
modifying the window matching
by slight parameters
can actually
upset how well GZIP
attaches to your data.
We also looked at how to
preprocess your content using
various forms of other command
line algorithms, like Zopfli
or 7-Zip, and then how to
transpose your JSON data, which
is fantastic for a lot
of your shopping sites.
Also, when you combine that
with the dense code boosting,
which is more cutting edge
text preprocessing data,
you start getting a sense
that the web is not done yet.
You're not locked into
your form that you have.
Then you can start looking at
the delta compression methods
and start looking at the
ways to actually combine
your data in different
ways to reduce duplication
and complexity in the
content that you have.
And when you apply
all this together,
you start getting
a vision of the web
that we can actually
control more of our data
to reduce the sizes and actually
get around a lot of the hitches
and problems that
GZIP presents to us.
So with that, thank you
for your time today.
I really appreciate
you listening
to this ramble on some very
hard compression stuff.
If you're interested
in more, I highly
recommend you check
out html4rocks.com.
I recently put up
two articles there
on text compression
for web developers
as well as image compression
for web developers,
and these are generally
meant to be opener tutorials
to introduce you to different
terminology and different
algorithms and how
they're being used.
Once again, definitely check
out the #perfmatters hashtag.
A lot of smart people are there.
And join the Google+ Web
Performance community.
You can actually see the
short link there on the side
as goo.gl/webperf.
Again, a great place to talk
about performance problems
and find issues.
That's it for me.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
Here's how you get a
hold of me for email
and other various
social media times.
Thanks, once again, for tuning
in to this episode of Google
Developers Live.
I hope to see you again soon.
Thanks.